>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Adam Kushner: Good morning.
I am Adam Kushner.
I am the editor of the Washington
Post Sunday Outlook section,
which is our home for
ideas, essays and arguments
and personal narratives and
also thankfully our home
for our nonfiction book coverage.
The Post is very, very happy
to have been a charter sponsor
of the National Book
Festival for many years.
Before we get started, a couple
quick orders of business.
I want to remind everybody
that you guys can donate
to help support the festival,
which is a really cool event.
All the information
is in your program.
And that after Sidney
Blumenthal finishes,
there will be a Q and
A time permitting.
In addition, he is going to be
doing a book signing downstairs
from 12 to one.
So in my decade and a half of living
in Washington, a lot has changed.
But one thing that
has not changed is
that this city is very much
a place of casts and sets.
And sometimes these groups, the
journalists and the politicians
and the operatives and the
policy scholars and the lobbyists
and the diplomats and
the advocates --
sometimes they have
symbiotic relationships
and sometimes parasitic ones.
And sometimes they do
not interact at all.
But rarely does somebody
pass between them.
And almost never with the
facility and the adaptability
and the skill of Sid Blumenthal.
Sidney starts his career
as a journalist
at the New Republic and
the Washington Post.
He worked two of my
alma maters as well.
And then he covered
Washington for the New Yorker,
which is generally regarded
as the summit of analytic
and narrative political coverage
that post covering D.C. In his work
as a journalist before, he
was an early detection system
for a problem we all know very well.
He coined the term the
permanent campaign.
Then, Sidney went into the
administration and he served
as President Clinton's
concierge for his second term,
where his portfolio bestrode every
political issue in the white house.
Afterward, he returned to
journalism where he worked at Salon
and also wrote books about the
Clinton and Bush administrations.
Now, Sidney has gotten into probably
his most ambitious project yet --
giving Abraham Lincoln
the Robert Caro treatment.
I cannot think of an American
political figure more relevant
to contemporary debates.
The first of the four volumes of
this series -- A Self Made Man --
started of course at the beginning.
And I remember reading the
coverage of it when it first came
out the word magisterial
appeared frequently.
We gave it a nice review also.
Now, Sidney has just dropped
Wrestling With His Angel,
The Second Volume, which
covers the years 1849 to 1856,
which is the battle against
Stephen Douglas and the rise
of a new political
party, the Republicans.
He could not have picked
a better moment for a book
about political realignment.
And so now please help me invite
him up here to talk about it.
Sidney Blumenthal.
[ Applause ]
>> Sidney Blumenthal:
Great to be here.
Thank you Adam for
those very kind remarks.
I am honored to be
here at the Library
of Congress National Book Festival.
Last night at the first
event, I had a conversation
with David McCullough, who
had just finished up next door
and said we really need Lincoln now.
And he said we need
them all [laughter].
The Library of Congress building,
one of the most magnificent
buildings
in the country did not used to
be such a distinguished address.
It used to be the location of a row
of boarding houses facing the
Capitol, inhabited by congressmen.
And one of those was
Abraham Lincoln.
He lived on that site
in the fourth one in.
That he was a [inaudible] Whig.
That was the party of Lincoln.
And he lived in a boarding
house with Whigs.
But it was also known as Abolition
House because it was the center
of anti-slavery operations
in the District of Columbia.
And I also want to say I am very
happy to be here speaking to those
of you who are fellow
Washingtonians.
So, the Washington Post in talking
about the National Book
Festival said it is a chance
to hear people imitate Charles
Dickens and take selfies.
I do not know that Dickens
took selfies [laughter].
But I will do my poor imitation of
Dickens talking about this second
of four volumes about the
political life of Abraham Lincoln.
This volume I have entitled
Wrestling With His Angel.
I have taken it from the
story of Jacob from the Bible.
Of Jacob wrestling through a long
night with an angel or himself
and emerging at dawn as somebody
else, having resolved himself.
And assuming a new identity.
He takes a new name.
The name he takes is Israel.
And something like that
happened with Lincoln.
But it happened in
his wilderness years.
Years lasting from 1849 to 1856.
And he assumed a new identity.
So, let me pretend to
be Dickens for a minute.
The more time I have spent
with Abraham Lincoln,
the more I have come to
understand that his words
and actions were the careful result
of his intense self discipline.
The silences that his law
partner, William Henry Herndon,
and his friends described as
his melancholy were also a mask
for his concentration,
intellectual absorption and focus.
His depression and his other
feelings deepened his self awareness
and spurred his self education,
which informed his
acute understanding
of human nature and politics.
Even when his life seemed to have
been reduced to insignificance,
he was scanning the horizons
and interpreting its signs.
The young Lincoln in
his first formal speech
at the Springfield
Lyceum for Young Men
in 1838 saw importance
of a crisis to come.
At what point then, he said, is the
approach of danger to be expected.
I am sir, if it ever reach us,
it must bring up amongst us.
It cannot come from abroad.
If destruction be our lot,
we must ourselves be
its author and finisher.
Now, Wrestling With His Angel
describes Lincoln's dark night
of the soul.
Lincoln coming to his
revelation of a house divided,
from which he emerged as the
recognizable Lincoln of history.
He would be that man
until his assassination.
After Abraham Lincoln's one term
in the Congress and his return
to his spare law office
in Springfield,
he started into distance
for long periods of time.
His partner, Herndon,
recalled him breaking one
of his prolonged silences
with a cry of anguish.
The political world was
dead, Herndon wrote.
Things were stagnant and all
hope for progress in the line
of freedom seemed to be crushed out.
Lincoln was speculating with me
about the deadness of things.
And the despair, which
arose out of it.
And deeply regretting that his human
strength and power were limited
by his nature to rouse
and stir up the world.
He said gloomingly,
despairingly, sadly --
how hard, oh how hard it is to die
and leave one's country no better
than if one had never lived for it.
The world is dead to hope,
deaf to its own death struggle.
Made known by a universal
cry -- what is to be done?
Is anything to be done?
Who can do anything?
And how is it to be done?
Did you ever think of these things?
Almost as soon as Abraham Lincoln
came back to Springfield, his wife,
Mary Todd Lincoln, turned him right
around and sent him on a mission
to her hometown of Lexington,
Kentucky, to serve as co-counsel
to recover the Todd family
fortune, which was considerable.
Lincoln find himself
thrust into the vortex
of his native state's politics
turned into mortal combat
between antislavery
and proslavery forces.
The lawsuit and the
politics were intertwined.
So bear with me and follow
these threads if you will.
For nearly a decade Mary
Todd's father, John S. Todd,
Senator Henry Clay's business
partner and political ally,
had tried to rest the Todd
Estate from a man known
as Robert Wickliffe,
also called the old duke.
He had married Polly
Todd, a Todd cousin,
who held the estate but passed away.
Wickliffe was also the leader
of the virulently proslavery
movement in Kentucky.
John Todd running for the State
Senate against that movement,
though a slave holder himself,
was demonized with the worst word
that could ever be used against
anyone in politics -- abolitionist.
In the middle of the campaign,
in July 1849 he died of cholera.
Lincoln arrived to pursue
the family's case in October.
Just in time to observe the
proslavery movement triumphantly
rewrite the State Constitution
to eliminate the Kentucky Law
prohibiting the slave trade
within its borders.
Lincoln lost the case and the Todd
family lost the estate to Wickliffe.
At the same moment that the
political legacy of Henry Clay,
Lincoln's early bow
ideal of a statements
and Mary's beloved
father were destroyed.
If those events were not
sufficiently embittering,
there was another factor.
It was a profound,
but concealed factor.
From memoirs, journals
and pamphlets of the time,
a mystery underlying the Todd
heirs v. Wickliffe case emerges.
It was the Todd family secret.
There was a living heir.
He was Polly Todd's grandson,
the only child of her son,
who had died at a relatively
young age.
But this heir was not
a person under the law.
He was in fact a slave.
And he had been emancipated
and shipped to Liberia.
In 1878, this former slave,
the invisible man of the story,
and he had a name -- Alfred Francis
Russell was elected Vice President
of the Liberia.
And in 1883 he became President.
So that made him Mary Todd's second
relation to become a President.
Backing on away from Kentucky,
Lincoln spoke with John Todd Stuart,
his first law partner and
early political mentor,
a conservative old Whig.
The time would soon come in
which we must be democrats
or abolitionists, said Stuart.
And Stuart would eventually
join the democrats.
When that time comes, my mind
is made up, Lincoln replied.
The slavery question
cannot be compromised.
Lincoln expressed to
many of his friends,
his anger at the rising slave
power he had observed in Kentucky.
He was livid that an antislavery
Whig lawyer he knew there,
Samuel F. Miller, had been driven
out of the state for his views.
And President Lincoln would
appoint him to the Supreme Court.
Lincoln described privately
young thoughtless
and giddy headed Kentucky
slave holders
with slaves trudging behind them
the most glittering ostentatious
and displaying property in
the world -- human property.
Lincoln would get excited on the
question, said one of his friends
and believed that the
tendency of the times was
to make slavery universal.
He told another friend in a
few years we will be ready
to accept the institution
in Illinois
and the whole country will adopt it.
The Todd heir's case with its hidden
history left Lincoln smoldering
in private until he
emerged five years later.
But the time for Lincoln to step
forward had not come, not yet.
A great revolution was required
to bring Abraham Lincoln
out of the wilderness.
Lincoln's orbit in
these years revolved
around the eight judicial districts
of central Illinois day after day
with Judge David Davis
and our coterie.
I shall never forget the
first time I saw Mr. Lincoln,
recalled Leonard Sweet, a
criminal attorney, who became one
of Lincoln's closest colleagues and
friends and would be instrumental
in his political campaigns.
Sweet came to the town of Danville,
where Lincoln was trying cases.
This is his account -- when I called
at the hotel it was after dark
and I was told Lincoln was
upstairs in Judge Davis's room.
In the region where I
had been brought up,
the judge of the court was usually
a man of more or less gravity
so that he could not be approached
say with some degree of deference.
I was not a little abash therefore
after I had climbed the unbanistered
staircase to find myself
so near the presence and
dignity of Judge Davis,
in whose room I was told
I could find Mr. Lincoln.
In response to my timid knock,
two voices responded almost
simultaneously -- come in.
Imagine my surprise when the door
opened to find two men undressed
or rather dressed for bed
engaged in a lively battle
with pillows [laughter], tossing
them at each other's heads.
One a low heavyset man who leaned
against the foot of the bed
and puffed like a lizard answered
to the description of Judge Davis.
The other was a man
of tremendous stature.
Compared to Davis, he looked
as if he were eight feet tall.
He was encased in a long
indescribable garment,
yellow as saffron, which reached
to his heels and from beneath
which protruded two
of the largest feet.
I had up to that time been
in the habit of [inaudible].
this immense shirt, for a
shirt it must have been,
looked as if it had been literally
carved out of the original bolt
of flannel, of which it was made.
And the pieces joined
together without reference
to measurement or capacity.
The only thing that kept it
from slipping off the tall
and angular frame it covered was
the single button at the throat.
And I confessed to a
succession of shutters.
When I thought of what might
happen should that button
by any mischance lose its hold.
I cannot describe my
sensations at this apparition
with modest announcement,
my name is Lincoln --
strode across the room to
shake my trembling hand.
I will not say he reminded
me of Satan,
but he was certainly the ungodliest
figure I had ever seen [laughter].
Who was this Lincoln?
This Lincoln was not
an abolitionist,
but he was as he insisted
naturally antislavery.
His deepening understanding of
slavery in its full complexity
as a moral, political and
constitutional dilemma began
in his childhood among the primitive
baptist antislavery dissidence
in backwoods Kentucky and Indiana,
whose churches his
semiliterate parents attended.
As a boy, he rode down the
Mississippi River to New Orleans.
He was the original Huck Finn.
And he discovered that New Orleans
was an open air emporium of slaves
on auction, on gaudy
display and it shocked him.
As a Congressman in his single
term here in Washington,
he lived in a boarding
house -- Abolition House.
He experienced the invasion of
slave catchers coming to seize one
of the waiters as a fugitive slave.
Undoubtedly, he knew the secret
of the house where he lived.
That it was a station in
the Underground Railroad.
He denounced the Mexican
War as fraudulently started
and voted numerous times
against the expansion of slavery
in the new Western Territories
that had been gained in that war
with the quiet assistance
of the leading abolitionists
in the Congress he drafted
a bill for emancipation
in the District of Columbia.
Something he would make good
on even before the Emancipation
Proclamation was issued.
And it is why we in the District
today have Emancipation Day.
But that first bill of Lincoln's
never received even a single hearing
in the House of Representatives.
And then he came home to
an obscurity that seemed
as though it would never end.
At the lowest moment of
political despair and retreat
in American politics, to that time,
marked by a widespread loss of faith
and democracy itself, Lincoln
emerged with his cause.
Suddenly, in 1854 the once and
future rivals of Lincoln combined
to blow to smithereens
the cornerstone
of civil and political peace.
Senator Stephen A. Douglas of
Illinois, Lincoln's eternal rival
from the beginning of
his political career,
seeking a transforming
gesture that would carry him
to the Democratic Presidential
nomination in the White House joined
with Secretary of War, the Dick
Cheney of his day, Jefferson Davis
of Mississippi, heir
to slave holding wealth
and the de facto acting
President of the United States,
operating behind the
weakling, Franklin Pierce,
in their collaboration on
the Kansas Nebraska Act.
That act repealed the
Missouri Compromise
that had forbidden slavery north
of the line through the country
that prohibited it in the
north except for Missouri.
But now its repeal made possible the
extension of slavery to the west.
It made possible the nationalization
of slavery, Lincoln's nightmare.
And in a stroke the entire old
political order cracked apart.
We were thunderstruck and
stunned and we reeled and fell
in utter confusion, said Lincoln,
describing the atmosphere
of the early resistance.
But we rose each fighting, grasping
whatever he could reach, a sieve,
a pitchfork, a chopping
ax or a butcher's cleaver.
We struck in the direction
of the sound.
In two brief autobiographies,
Lincoln depicted himself
in his wilderness years as
strangely content in a kind
of internal exile becoming
nearly indifferent to politics,
immersed in his legal practice.
As he was contemplating his
race for the Presidency,
he told the Chicago Tribune
in 1854 his profession had
almost superseded the thought
of politics in his mind.
When the repeal of the
Missouri Compromise aroused him,
as he had never been before.
It was about this decisive juncture
in Lincoln's career that Herndon,
his law partner, wrote
of Lincoln's ambition.
That man who thinks Lincoln calmly
sat down and gathered his robes
around him, waiting for the people
to call him has a very
erroneous knowledge of Lincoln.
He was always calculating
and always planning ahead.
His ambition was a little
engine that knew no rest.
Now, Lincoln clung to the hull
of the sinking Whig
party longer than some.
But he also knew that a new
coalition against the extension
of slavery, the nationalization
of slavery must be organized.
In this period of party chaos,
Lincoln cast himself
into the whirlwind.
He sequestered himself in the
Law Library of the State Capitol
in Springfield and drafted a speech
against the Kansas Nebraska Act.
Stepping onto the podium to speak in
the Illinois Hall of Representatives
on October 4th, 1854, he never
again left the stage of history.
Lincoln, the defender of the
Declaration of Independence
and its precept all men are
created equal, invoked the blood
of the revolution, the
American Revolution.
Lincoln the Shakespearian pointed
to the moral wrong of slavery.
And alluded to his favorite
play, Macbeth and the scene
where Macbeth tries to
washout the spot of his guilt.
Lincoln said, like the bloody
hand you may wash it and wash it
and wash it, the red
witness of guilt still sticks
and stares horribly at you.
He was referring to slavery.
Now in this chaotic period,
many movements swirled
across the landscape
for and against slavery,
against immigrants
and against liquor.
But the nativist and temperance
movements confounded the development
of the antislavery war.
Meanwhile, antislavery
democrats and antislavery Whigs
with long grudges still regarded
each other with mutual suspicion.
Some people in the abolitionist
movement in Illinois understood,
had a political sense that
they needed a more proficient
and gifted political figure
to draw the elements together.
And that brought them
to Abraham Lincoln.
That brought them in fact to the
very platform where he was speaking
in the Illinois Hall
of Representatives
against the Kansas Nebraska Act.
And when he finished,
this small group
of radical abolitionist asked him
to join a meeting they were holding
that night for a group they
called the Republican Party.
It was a radical group.
And Lincoln dodged them.
He had a law case in
a distant county.
He would not attend this radical
group -- the Republican Party.
For years Lincoln turned
over in his mind the menace
of slavery to democracy.
Until in 1855 he envisioned the
prospect of what was to come.
I think that there is no peaceful
extinction of slavery in prospect
for us, he wrote his co-counsel
in the Todd heir's case,
George Robertson, Kentucky judge.
The signal failure of Henry Clay
and other good and great men in 1849
to affect anything in favor
of gradual emancipation
in Kentucky together with a
thousand other signs extinguishes
that hope utterly.
Yet, another complicating factor
entered into the equation.
Between 1845 and 1854 three
million immigrants arrived
in the United States.
The first great wave of immigration.
About 40 percent were poor Irish
Catholics fleeing the Potato Famine.
About another 40 percent were
Germans fleeing the crushing
of the Liberal Democratic
Revolution in Germany of 1848.
Conservative Protestants viewed
the Irish especially as a source
of crime corruption and poverty.
Both the Irish and Germans
were beer drinkers [laughter].
A habit that aroused temperance
crusaders, who condemned them
as drunken, lazy and sinful.
A new party arouse in this
period of party disintegration.
It was a masked political party.
It was an anti-immigrant party.
And the party was known
as the Know-Nothing Party.
It took that name because
members were told that like,
that when they were asked
if they were members,
they were to reply I know nothing.
It sprang from a small
native [inaudible]
in New York City called the Order
of the Star Spangled Banner.
Within months after
the 1852 election,
it attracted an estimated
membership of more than a million.
Its program had one
plank and one plank only.
Only native born Protestants
would be allowed
to hold public office
in the United States.
And it had a slogan -- Americans
only shall govern America.
As the crisis deepened,
Lincoln wondered how he could be
effective fighting slavery while
maintaining his identity in
the crumbling Whig party.
On August 24th, 1855 he wrote to
his long time intimate friend,
Joshua Speed, with whom he had
shared a room in Springfield,
but who had now moved
to Kentucky to preside
over his family's plantation.
Lincoln and Speed agreed on
many things and disagreed
on other things including
on the question of slavery.
But in the forefront
of Lincoln's thinking
at the time was the threat
of the Know-Nothings.
I am not a Know-Nothing.
That is certain, Lincoln
wrote Speed.
How could I be?
How can anyone who abhors the
oppression of Negroes be in favor
of degrading classes
of white people?
Our progress in degeneracy
appears to me to be pretty rapid.
As a nation, we began by declaring
that all men are created equal.
We now practically read it all men
are created equal, except Negroes.
When the Know-Nothings get control,
it will read all men are
created equal, except negroes,
and foreigners and Catholics.
When it comes to this I should
prefer emigrating to some country
where they make no pretence
of loving liberty --
to Russia, for instance [laughter],
where despotism can be taken pure,
and without the base
alloy of hypocrisy.
Even then, Lincoln
had a way with words.
State by state the new Republican
Party was being organized.
And in Illinois, a group
of antislavery newspaper editors
invited Lincoln to join them
as their leader at a meeting
to organize a convention
of the new party.
Lincoln was absent at the
time, recalled Herndon.
And believing I knew what
his feelings and judgement
on the vital questions of the
hour were, I took the liberty
to sign his name to call.
John Todd Stuart, Lincoln's
first law partner,
the conservative old Whig,
rushed into the office trying
to remove Lincoln's endorsement.
Stuart excitedly asked Herndon
if Lincoln had signed the
abolitionists call in the newspaper.
I answered in the negative,
adding that I had signed his name.
To the question did Lincoln
authorize you to sign it?
I returned an emphatic no.
Then, exclaimed startled
and indignant Stuart,
you have ruined Abraham Lincoln.
I thought I understood Lincoln
thoroughly, Herndon said.
But in order to vindicate myself
if assailed, I immediately sat
down after Stuart had rushed out
of the office and wrote Lincoln,
who was then in Tazewell
County attending court.
A brief account of what he had done
and how much stir it was creating
in the ranks of his
conservative friends.
If he approved or disapproved
my course,
I asked him to write or
telegraph me at once.
In a brief time came his answer.
Alright, go ahead.
We will meet you, radicals and all.
At that meeting on February
22nd, 1856, George Schneider,
editor of the german language
newspaper Staats-Zeitung,
proposed a plank denouncing
the Know-Nothings.
The nativists present
strongly opposed it.
The conference threatened
to collapse.
Schneider announced he would
submit his resolution to Lincoln
and abide by his decision.
Gentleman, declared Lincoln,
the resolution introduced
by Mr. Schneider is nothing new.
It is already contained in the
Declaration of Independence.
And you cannot form a new
party on other principles.
This declaration of Mr.
Lincoln, Schneider recalled,
saved the resolution and in fact
helped to establish the new party
on the most liberal
Democratic basis.
Lincoln's judgement made
possible the creation
of the Illinois Republican Party,
which became the instrument
that would in four years carry him
to the Republican nomination
for president.
But he could not foresee
that distant future,
nor could he predict the shocking
10 days that shook the world
that would soon polarize and
clarify the coming conflict.
On May 19th, 1856,
Senator Charles Sumner
of Massachusetts delivered his
speech on the attack on democracy,
the crime against Kansas then being
taken over by the slave power.
On May 21st, two days later,
an army of nearly one
thousand proslavery Missourians
under a red banner inscribed
Southern Rights rampaged
into the Free State town of
Lawrence, Kansas and ransacked it.
The next day in the United States
Senate while Sumner sat writing
at his desk, Congressman
Preston Brooks
of South Carolina approached
him as he was sitting
and battered him relentlessly
on his head
with a gold handled
cane nearly killing him
in retribution for his speech.
Blood streamed across
the floor of the senate.
Two days later, May 24th,
along Pottawatomie Creek
in Kansas radical abolitionist
John Brown
and his followers hacked
five proslavery men to death
in the middle of the night.
And five days later, on May
29th, Abraham Lincoln stood
on the platform of the new
party that he had founded
in Illinois, the Republican Party.
Within two years of assuming his
new identity as a Republican,
Lincoln sounded his
own note of destiny.
Lincoln's language was drenched not
only Shakespeare, but also drawn
from two passages of
the King James Bible.
From the Gospel of Mark -- if a
kingdom is divided against itself,
that kingdom cannot stand.
And if a house is divided
against itself,
that house will not
be able to stand.
From the Gospel of Luke --
every kingdom divided
against itself is laid waste
and a divided household falls.
On June 16th, 1858 declaring his
candidacy for the U.S. Senate
against Stephen A. Douglas,
Lincoln explained --
if we could first know where we are
and whether we are we are tending,
we could better judge what
to do and how to do it.
Now recall just a few years
later, he was despairing.
He wondered what is to be done.
He thought the political
world was dead.
He had not thought
through the crisis.
And now the crisis was upon him.
And this is what Lincoln said --
a house divided against
itself cannot stand.
I believe this government cannot
endure permanently half slave
and half free.
I do not expect the
union to be dissolved.
I do not expect the house to fall.
But I do expect it will
cease to be divided.
It will become all one
thing or all the other.
By now, Lincoln's sense
of historical timing
and political timing
had become acute.
Two weeks after his
defeat to Douglas,
he wrote a friend - -
the fight must go on.
The cause of civil liberty must not
be surrendered at the end of one
or even one hundred defeats.
In 1860 beginning his campaign
for the Republican
Presidential nomination,
in his speech at the Cooper Union in
New York City, Lincoln concluded --
neither let us be slandered from
our duty by false accusations
against us, nor frightened from
it by menaces of destruction
to the government, nor
of dungeons to ourselves.
Let us have faith that
right makes might.
And in that faith let
us to the end dare
to do our duty as we understand it.
Lincoln's political education
was long, but many of the moments
of Lincoln's awakening
from his period
of political slumber
were not publically known
until years after his death.
At about the time he was thinking
this through, this problem of,
he in early 1855 traveling the
county court circuit staying
overnight in a boarding house,
his discussion with a former judge
and fellow lawyer, T. Lyle Dickey,
another conservative old Whig,
went on deep into the night.
Judge Dickey contended that
slavery was an institution
which the constitution recognized
and which could not be disturbed.
Lincoln argued that ultimately
slavery must become extinct recalled
another Illinois lawyer
who was present.
After a while, said Dickey,
we went upstairs to bed.
There were two beds in our room.
And I remember that Lincoln sat
up in his nightshirt on the edge
of the bed arguing
the point with me.
At last, we went to sleep.
Early in the morning I woke up
and there was Lincoln half
sitting up in the bed.
Dickey, said Lincoln, I tell you
this nation cannot exist half slave
and half free.
Oh Lincoln, replied Dickey,
go to sleep [laughter].
A little later, but in this period,
1857 a free black woman known
as Polly appeared at
the office of Lincoln
and Herndon with a tale of woe.
Her young son had hired himself out
on a steamboat in the Mississippi,
something like what Lincoln
had done years earlier.
But when he reached New Orleans
without free papers proving he
was not a slave, he was imprisoned
and about to be sold into slavery.
Lincoln appealed to the
Governor of Illinois,
who informed Lincoln
he could do nothing.
Lincoln appealed to the Governor of
Louisiana, who rejected his request.
So, Lincoln drew up a subscription
list and Herndon raised money
from Lincoln's friends
in Springfield.
Lincoln drew from his account
of the Springfield Marine
and Life Insurance
Company what he had.
And they located an
agent in New Orleans
to purchase the young man's liberty.
And soon his prison door
swung open and he was returned
to Springfield to his mother.
Lincoln had bought a slave
in order to free him.
It was Abraham Lincoln's
first act of emancipation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I think we have five minutes and if,
I think I can take
a couple questions
if anyone has a question
about Lincoln.
Sir?
>> Can you hear me?
>> Sidney Blumenthal: Yes.
>> I say this with humility, as you
know there are more books written
about Lincoln than anything else.
What lead you to believe that
you would be able to add to this
and what you just said, what
has not been known previously
by other authors?
>> Sidney Blumenthal: Thank
you for that question.
When I fell down this rabbit hole of
Abraham Lincoln, I had no idea when
or how I would emerge and I am
still down this rabbit hole writing.
But I thought that what I had
to offer was my own experience
as a journalist, as somebody
who understood Washington,
as somebody who grew up in
Illinois whose family is involved
in Illinois politics and as somebody
who worked in the White House
and participated in and
observed a presidency first hand.
And so I thought that my
skills might be brought to bear
to provide some original insight
and interpretation on Lincoln.
And I hope I have done so
in the first two volumes
and in the next two to come,
particularly about the house
divided, country torn apart
and the emergence of
Lincoln's political leadership
and how he dealt with that and
how he developed his argument
and his words and where he took it
from because he was only one person.
And how he managed to
develop and find the means
that eventually would save the
country and lead to emancipation.
>> What was the Whigs Party, what
were their views on immigration?
>> Sidney Blumenthal: Well,
there were no laws on immigration
in the United States at the time.
The question was what were
the views on immigration?
There were no laws
against immigration.
People just came into the country.
But there was a lot of prejudice
against this new wave of immigration
of the Irish and the
Germans particularly.
And this movement developed
against it.
Lincoln, as I noted, abhorred
the Know-Nothing movement.
But he only did so in private.
And he operated behind the scenes
believing that it had to be undone
by political means through
the operation of his friends.
And Lincoln did work
behind the scenes
to undermine the Know-Nothing
movement, engaged in even methods
that we are familiar with
today in places like Chicago,
where he destroyed the
Know-Nothing Party entirely
without any fingerprints
using his friends.
But he did so with the belief that
he needed to draw them and get them
to participate in this
antislavery coalition
that became the Republican Party.
And until he end.
As he told Owen Lovejoy, one of
the leading radical abolitionists
who had come to Lincoln and
wanted his leadership, he said --
you know the time had not
come yet in the mid 1850's.
But eventually it did.
And Lincoln had to wait
for the right time.
And that is one of the
other things about Lincoln.
He steps. He says he would take
a step depending on the timing.
And some people would
criticize him for being passive
and vacillating and compromising.
But he said, I never took a step
back once I took a step forward.
And in order to take a step forward,
he wanted to have the greatest
possible political support
for what he was doing.
And that was part of
his political genius.
Just one more question.
>> Thank you very much for such a
wonderful synopsis of your story.
I could have listened
to you for hours.
>> Sidney Blumenthal: Thank you.
>> You were so enthralling.
I am sure the audience
agrees with me.
It was just outstanding.
>> Sidney Blumenthal: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> My question is not about Lincoln,
but it is about your perspective
on the waves of history
going forward
and back and forward and back.
I am sure you have seen that
with your research and studies.
And there are many of us today who
admire the intellect of Lincoln
and Kennedy and other
notable presidents.
And we are struggling with the
events in our present condition.
And I was wondering if you might
have a chance to put some of that
in perspective so that we
could leave this Festival
with hope [laughter] perhaps.
[Applause].
>> Sidney Blumenthal:
Thank you for that.
[ Applause ]
Let me refer to Abraham
Lincoln [laughter].
In that speech at Springfield Lyceum
in 1828 called on the perpetration
of our political institutions,
in which Lincoln warns
of our own self destruction
from within.
He says, there is a
flaw in our system.
And this is what Lincoln says.
He says, there may be a
man who emerges seeking --
and these are Lincoln's
words, not mine --
celebrity and fame and distinction
beyond what is normal in politics.
And he may seek to trample
down what exists in order
to achieve distinction for himself.
When that happens, said Lincoln,
the people must unite together
and then Lincoln's words --
act intelligently in
order to oppose him.
Now Lincoln may have had
in mind Stephen A. Douglas,
his great rival [laughter].
But he was warning against
the danger of [inaudible]
and how might upset
the American democracy.
And Lincoln's words
echo through the ages.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.